So you really have to see this video of a
Fox News host admitting that conservatives
are total and complete hypocrites.
And many times I've said if Obama did this,
if Hillary did this, they wouldn't just be
calling for their impeachment.
They'd be calling for their heads.
Example, if Chelsea Clinton had 5 percent
of the role that Ivana Trump has had in the
Trump administration, if Chelsea was sitting
with other world leaders at the G-20, sitting
in for our secretary of state.
Fox News would be 24/7 demanding Hillary Clinton
be tarred and feathered.
If Obama, at a press briefing, played a five
minute propaganda video like Donald Trump
did on Monday this week during a hundred year
pandemic, they would be calling for Barack
Obama's head.
And when Trump has now gone full authoritarian,
claiming that he has the absolute authority
to open or close a state at his demand, that
governors must do what he says, any supposedly
small government conservative who believes
in states rights or federalism in the constitution
and says nothing is a gigantic, glaring hypocrite.
And Bret BAIER on Fox News called it out.
Some Fox News people like Brit HUME have been
sort of just waving off Trump's growingly
a growing, belligerent authoritarianism.
But Bret Bayer admits it's so good for Bret.
Check this out.
Bret is asked, how do you see the battle between
Trump and governors going in the future over
over this issue of opening and closing states?
Here is what Bret BAIER says.
How do you see this shaping up across the
country with the president, with his fiery
statements last night and the governors trying
to pour a little cold water on it?
First of all, the constitution is pretty clear
and constitutional scholars will say that
this is not the president's flicking on the
switch.
It's the governors and the local authorities
that have that going forward.
I think that there's a proxy here in that,
you know, one, if President Obama had said
those words that you heard from President
Trump, that the the authority is total with
the presidency.
You know, conservatives heads would have exploded
across the board to a week ago.
There was a lot of coverage of saying, why
isn't there a national stay at home order?
The constitution is clear.
Trump doesn't have the authority.
The governors have the authority.
That's the correct analysis.
But Bret goes into the hypocrisy, which is
what I like.
If Obama ever said something like this, right
wingers would be slamming Obama's authoritarian
one world government, whatever.
And in fact, many of them were calling Barack
Obama a dictator any way.
They're silent right now.
And Trump is increasingly, you know, the things
that Obama was accused of being Trump increasingly
is.
And very few people are actually calling it
out.
So, of course, you know, disclaimer one moment
of truth and clarity on Fox does not change
that.
They continue to big picture, be water carriers
for the disinformation of Trump through the
Corona virus pandemic.
But here's the really scary thing about Fox
News to me.
If they are successfully able to spin this
presidency into something that maintains 40
percent support for Donald Trump, they can
spin anything to 40 percent support.
And what I mean by that is this is by far
the most outrageous presidency we've had in
the modern media era.
George W. Bush was a disaster.
He was a warmonger.
I'm not praising George W. Bush, but George
W. Bush was much more of a standard right
winger.
And the right wing media playbook for how
to defend a standard right winger is very
well-written.
There was nothing new there.
We know that that will have roughly 40 percent
support.
Fox News has been able to evolve on the fly
and figure out how do we defend anything Donald
Trump does.
And if they can do it with Trump and keep
him at 40 percent support, I fear that there
is no president.
So crazy that Fox News would not be able to
help them maintain 40 percent support no matter
what they do, no matter what they say.
And we talk about things are much different
now than they were for Nixon in the 1970s.
Maybe if Nixon had Fox News in the 70s, he
wouldn't have had to resign.
Maybe if Trump didn't have something like
Fox News and the entire apparatus that's around
it, maybe he would have suffered more consequences
for his harebrained actions so far.
That's a really scary idea.
And what Fox has proven is that they can reframe
almost anything and still keep 40 percent
of the country saying Trump's doing a good
job and that should scare the hell out of
all of us.
And it's it's reminiscent of George Orwell's
1984, but it's also reminiscent of the kind
of manufacture of consent outlined in George
Orwell's other novel, Animal Farm, which I
recently re-read, and many elements of what
is going on increasingly today with Fox News
and Trump and media coverage.
And the virus makes me think of Animal Farm,
and that's very, very bad.